48 hours has new details about one of
the tragic deaths connected to the
family of prominent south carolina
lawyer alex murdoch 19 year old mallory
beach was killed in a boating accident
in 2019 on mordock's boat murdoch's son
paul was allegedly driving it beech's
family has been silent on the accident
until now for this week's 48 hours nikki
patis spoke with beach's aunt and a
first responder who was at the scene of
the crash
where's your emergency
we're in a boat crash on archer creek on
february 24 2019 six young friends were
out partying on the beaufort river on a
boat owned by the murdoch family when
they crashed
on board was alex murdoch's 19-year-old
son paul what bridges paul what bridge
is this anthony cook was there with his
19 year old girlfriend mallory beach
mallory's aunt lynne revis the last
thing she told me was she loved me
just hours before the crash surveillance
cameras captured paul murdock using his
brother's id to buy beer he's holding
the beer up he's celebrating
michael dewitt editor of the hampton
county guardian says later paul and a
friend were seen drinking at a bar on
the river
he pounded a couple of shots got back in
the boat it was kind of a sad moment
when you see mallory i think it's the
last moment that anybody captured an
image of her alive
about an hour later the boat slammed
into a bridge piling that's when mallory
disappeared
there's six of us and one is missing
then beaufort county deputy sheriff
stephen domino was one of the first on
the scene
anthony cook told him he saw paul
murdock driving the boat just before the
crash you all know alex murdock
all right i know that that's his son
good luck
nearly two months after the boat crash
paul was charged with causing the death
of mallory beach he pleaded not guilty
but the case will never go to trial on
june 7 2021 alex murdoch called police
and said he'd found paul and his wife
maggie shot dead on one of their
properties maggie and paul please hurry
nikki batiste this is all over the place
this case are investigators saying if
the boat crash is in fact related to the
double murder or connected in any way so
the investigators are staying staying
really tight-lipped about a motive a
suspect but alex murdoch's attorneys
have admitted that he is a person of
interest in the double murders but i've
spent a lot of time in south carolina i
talk to a lot of locals there is
speculation
that this double murder might be revenge
for the boat crash but here's what's so
crazy about this case there are six
investigations going going on all around
the murdoch family we've got the boat
crash a double murder the death of
another teenage boy a suicide scheme
missing money from a law firm and the
death of the murdoch family housekeeper
a few years ago what does the family
think
mallory's family yeah mallory's family
in a civil lawsuit very clearly says
they believe paul murdoch was driving
the boat that he was drunk it crashed
their beautiful daughter died nicki i
cannot wait to watch this yeah so many
twists and turns you can watch nikki's
report the murdoch
mysteries let's get that out of my mouth
tomorrow night on 48 hours at 10 9
central right here on cbs